colby covington continues to win big  outside of the octagon earlier in the  week covington made headlines for  placing seventh in florida's biggest  poker tournament ever and just two days  later he took the top spot in event 22  at the seminole hard rock poker open  with the win covington takes home a  trophy and a cool 25  875 dollars of prize money speaking to  seminolehardrockpokeropen.com covington  talked about finishing seventh earlier  in the week and the first place finish  i wanted to come back and prove that  wasn't just a fluke and show that i  could play with the best players in the  world it's a surreal feeling it's been a  long journey to finally get a trophy  here at seminole hard rock this is my  home casino and i love playing here  luckily for me i fought at the highest  levels on pay-per-view and in front of  sold-out arenas like madison square  garden i'm used to the nerves and i know  how to channel them and use them in the  right way